good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday it is
rainy and nasty here in new york but we
are here
to be the bright balls of sunshine that
i know we can be i know we can be
as well it's not raining yet yes it is
it is when i walked and i was like
drip drop drip drop like you know about
to start i made it just in time
interesting so that's why the elephant
is not in the room today
how if you if you i didn't mean it like
that but like if you
[ __ ] body shame i don't know oh my
god one more time that's on youtube
yelling the police that's on you that
your mind went there no
you say it all the time in one way or
another
elephant yeah not that but you are
always complimenting on his body
and that's complimenting i'm always
complimenting him
commenting on his body and i just want
to know as theo's representative
we're done with it okay i'm just done
with it i want you to know that i
don't say anything about his body i
think he is such a beautiful physique
and when i said the elephant in the room
it was a figure of speech that i i
understand actually this time i don't
think you were body shaming but just as
a general rule of thumb you do do it a
lot
and also like justice for elephants
because they're born that way so like
you associating elephantness
with being big um no actually i don't i
look at the tongue
i'm not following you there because
elephants are enormous
um also like can you actually not talk
about elephants like i'm still really
recovering from this documentary i
watched on saturday
cher and the loneliest elephant and it
was like kavon has really etched out a
special place in my heart so
we just need to move on okay moving on
from elephants i was just trying to say
theo's not here today because of the
rain
i was trying to [ __ ] say i also have
some like errands to
run today so i just figured um best to
be
hands-free best to be theo free
unfortunately um
i did want to point out that today
jackie well i actually have decided this
was a claudia initiative yeah um i feel
like
we should talk about it because i
brought up the gavels today because i
don't know what we're going to talk
about today
i just feel like justice is going to
need to be certain
you're going to need a lighter yep it's
not the same
i know but you need to just put some
padding down because that's abrasive
so um let's talk about it because i
brought out the gavels i've been meaning
to do it for a while i just feel like
they're such a part of our history
and it is difficult for me to look down
and say award-winning co-host the
morning breath
um but we could just scratch that out
yeah whatever you can't see from that
far away
also no but i want to talk about why do
you hate the gavels why do i hate the
gavel i know you do right
i don't hate the gavel yes you do i just
i didn't plan for any justice to be
served up today i wasn't feeling that
justice bug but actually we do have some
justice to serve up because
we have come full circle on something we
started the gavels and the justice and
our two figures we were serving up
justice for were david foster who i feel
has gotten justice and we've put that
one to bed when sarah and aaron foster
came on the show
justice was completely served like we
could literally have burdened these
we but the other person was chris
humphries
oh my god justice for chris humphries
and i feel that with the keeping up with
the kardashian ring
and like he got a little bit of justice
like justice was served do we need to
close down the show like
we have no like causes we have no causes
we are not cause driven anymore
like our pr that's crazy i can't believe
you put that together that is true that
is both why we started the show
yeah but i think that if we put our
heads together there's people out there
who deserve justice too 100
and i'm sure we say like their names all
the time yeah so i just thought like i
don't know if we're gonna need it today
but i just think the gavel should
constantly be within reach because
they're an integral part of who we are
and we shouldn't be ashamed of where we
came from i
am not ashamed of where we came from
whatsoever speaking of just like they're
a little loud
and so as long as you're not like
banging on the table like the gavels can
stay
no promises i want to get you like a
little gavel bang like this
like a matching mallard yes is that what
it's called
it sounds right um speaking of things
i'm not ashamed of
that segway's like a little delayed uh
today we have an amazing guest on the
show today we're so excited
we were talking last week about a guess
we were gonna have unfortunately she did
have to postpone but she came back
la la kent from vanderpump rules is here
we interviewed with her
via zoom so if you're listening as a
podcast just keep listening it'll be at
the end of the episode
and we did record with her on zoom so if
you want to watch on youtube that's
available on our channel now so
check that out i'm very excited so
exciting we
were fangirling i was fangirling plus i
just read her book and so i just felt
like so
in tune with lala and also the show
hasn't been on in so long
that you know sometimes your faves come
and go but like lala is someone
for me who will always just be like top
five favorite
people on television yeah i feel like
when we always like if we get asked like
who are ideal guests for your show like
in your top five of like kelly clarkson
kim lala like sometimes make it makes it
in there yeah like depending on the
season and like what's on tv
you know so i that's how strongly i feel
about her was a pleasure to talk to her
and see her doing so well and she shared
like some tea about the new season
yeah so it's a really she's an open book
for sure she is an open book and she
just wrote an open book 100
but there's always more for her to give
of lala so that was really fun check
that out also
um the bachelorette was on last night um
i
did not watch i was busy you know i'm in
like my olympic trial
phase like i had to watch that you're so
sporty and you know who's not sporty
other girls
and i'm not like other girls and
honestly i feel like i've been watching
a lot of track and field
and i feel so dumb do you know why it's
called track and field
um no no okay because like the children
they run on the track yeah it is the
running part and then
in the middle of the track is the field
and that's where they do like shot put
javelin so it's like track and field
that seems pretty self-explanatory no i
just like i just always thought like
track and field was
the running but it's all the sports the
ones on the tracks
and the ones on the field i'm sure if
you thought about it longer
you would have gotten there i also just
want to say like
we have within our midst like an olympic
toaster emma coburn and i was watching
last night the track and field she
didn't run she ran on um sunday and i'm
pretty sure she won the whole thing
she's like literally gonna be like
american pride and she's a toaster
yeah and like she's such a big deal in
the running industry because like i was
watching
um the runs last night and like her
husband's like a really big time
i had the reds last night and her
husband's like a really big time coach
and he coached all these girls who were
like killing it so it's like
you'd love to see toaster energy just
like radiating throughout the olympic
industry
i think toaster energy and olympic
energy are actually quite
similar they're like super patriotic
super like
positive skinny vibes cheering
excitement
i think like maybe we should make all
the olympians olympians on the flight to
tokyo like listen to episodes of the
morning toast 100
blasted through the planes yeah blasted
oh that's not a good word
no like blasted through the playing
flare blair yeah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
the planes um we have a great show we do
have a great show i just wanted to give
a little content update
on my end because i've been reading and
last night i finished this book i was
reading called the second season
by emily adrian it doesn't come up till
july thanks netgalley
um but i didn't love it i think maybe if
you're a big fan of basketball you would
like it more it's like all about
basketball so
yeah she's a sports reporter oh that
sounds good yeah so but it was too much
basketball for me
yeah i have not read a book in like so
long well last night i started malibu
rising because i was just like it's time
to treat myself
yeah and margot is reading it dana read
it so we're going to do a mini recap on
the next redheads episode
so if you want to start it like we could
talk about it too i know that's just
like a book i'm saving and i don't want
to read it in my sad [ __ ] one-bedroom
apartment like i want to read it on the
beach
let it transport you like i guess
there's actually a few things i like
need to read
um and i just i'm gonna run cuz like i
started the new lauren weisberger book
stunk i started we were liars that like
everyone on tick tock was like felling
over
stunk um so now i'm just like feeling
like i can't win you know
i know i like malibu rising after i read
malibu rising and then the redheads book
the nature of fragile things which i've
heard is
amazing by susan meisner episode drops
next week
i'm making a pack to myself to no longer
read bad stupid books
like really read the books that are like
renowned top of the list like just read
the good books yeah because you're going
to each
take longer and they're harder like i i
want to get more out of it there's
nothing worse than like wasting your
time on a stupid book
what do you mean by stupid like i'm not
like that i'm cringing the characters
are not american royals
yeah like they're not the characters are
not inspiring like
i'm not learning anything and i'm just
like it's as if i'm watching like
the dumbest reality tv show okay you
know yeah
so that's i mean i've been reading
serious books but then what starts to
happen is like
you know if you don't like one of those
and you're like wow i just want
something light that i can freeze
through
i just feel like you don't just swear
off like a whole catalog like just read
what you feel like no i'm not gonna
swear them off but i'm gonna
make a concerted effort to like read
better books
you know hashtag do better yeah no
that's that's what's up for me
so we've great show i think we should
get into it because i want everyone to
hear our
lala kent interview and i really don't
have much else to share i've just been
like you know
in the track and field oh okay well then
without further a
do where are you not here as previously
mentioned
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
zip recruiter if you're a business owner
who's hiring you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person
whether that's not finding enough
applicants with the right skills or
experience
there's too many resumes to sort through
but you need to hire asap
and you don't know where to post your
job to reach the right people that's why
hiring can feel like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job to a board
but then all you can do is hope that the
right person comes along which is why
you should try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com toast
so when you post a job on zip recruiter
it gets out to over a hundred top job
sites in one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
in fact zip recruits are so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring hiring needs including
the morning toast we can attest to the
fabulousness
of zip recruiter so while other
companies overwhelm you with way too
many options
zip recruiter finds you what you're
looking for the needle in the haystack
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast again the only way to get
ziprecruiter for free is
ziprecruiter.com
toast t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire
love it okay first story a-rod is
partying with ben affleck's ex
lindsay shookus this is so lame this is
so sad you guys a-rod was spotted
hanging out with ben affleck's ex
lindsay shookus at her birthday party on
saturday a video obtained by page six
reveals
in the clip the two are sitting right
beside each other at an intimate
backyard
gathering the timing of shookus and
a-rod's hangout sparks interest given
that their respective x's affleck and
j-lo
rekindled romance why can't you say ben
affleck i guess i did say affleck again
yeah
just something cute about yourself
you're not like other girls
so quirky the timing of shookus and
a-rats hang out
sparks interest giving that their
respective exes affleck and j-lo
rekindled romance continues to heat up
you threw a wrench into my
sorry i just want to say like i went
from having
like being obsessed with a-rod mostly
because of his relationship with j-lo
and like his you know being on shark
tank there was just like so much that i
loved about him for the last few years
and the last six months i have lost
every ounce of respect i have for for
him first of all like the madison
lacroix thing like
don't [ __ ] around on jlo respect gone
second
some of those photos that came out from
his promo um
for his new mail makeup company like
sorry they did make me laugh they just
looked weird
um two three this like this is so
[ __ ] losery i can't oh
and oh my god i totally forgot i was on
tick tock yesterday
literally i am i'm obsessed with kids um
who are on tick tock
whose parents are famous it's like i
it's my favorite kind of content to
follow and so i've followed a lot of
people and so
the algorithm knows what to serve me and
i saw one of a-rod's daughters
and they did such an inappropriate dance
like i literally the comments were like
it's not too late to delete this
call your therapist like it was really
inappropriate like so there's just a lot
of things happening like i do not [ __ ]
with a rod anymore like i actually have
zero respect for him
yeah i agree usually when we like see
like revenge
x's getting together like sometimes
we're here for it you know like when
madison lacroix and jay cutler were
that was fun um speaking but just like
when you're meant to be so
a-list like there's just things that you
are above there's lines you don't cross
and but you did it yeah i just think
this is so illusory and i actually have
so many thoughts about like jlo and
a-rod because
that company hims that was like his
makeup for men company
also had a hers and it was j.lo's
company it was like a hair product and i
just saw a commercial for it's like
they're still in business together
damn hymns and hers or something that
sucks yeah
i mean jlo seems to be living her abs
sucks
so yeah it's just like annoying to be
like tethered to someone when you're so
clearly moved on
yeah which is so crazy how did these two
even meet
like she's not really like a traditional
celebrity she's an snl
producer a rep for page six said that
there's nothing romantic there but um
rep for sorry a-rod said there's nothing
romantic there that they've been friends
for 15 years
what a [ __ ] lie what a coincidence
yeah what let me guess they met on snl
15 years ago when he like that's just
not it i mean that's
that could have happened no i'm sorry it
doesn't
i agree i agree this is so losery like i
just
we keep reporting on stories and this is
like the segment like
let's lose more respect for a-rod like
he's such a loser now and i thought he
was like so cool and i'd love too much
love
it's just so crazy how your opinion of
someone can change so drastically so
quickly
yeah it's really crazy now like when i
see a story about him
i'm getting close to like fully chinaing
him like yeah i think he's such like a
media like
weasel like i'm just i'm really done
with him no i totally agree and
understand
thank you so much for being
understanding at this time you're
welcome
are you ready for our next story which
is a little streaming news that's really
going to shake up the industry
netflix and steven spielberg have struck
a surprising production deal in a jaws
dropping turn of events oh filmmaker
steven spielberg has struck a multi-year
deal to supply movies for netflix
steel spielberg's amblin partners and
netflix announced an agreement in which
the studio will make multiple new films
for the streaming giant
over the course of the agreement the
netflix steel has no restrictions
regarding budget or
genre insiders told the hollywood
reporter and this partnership does not
impact his relationship with comcast
corpse universal pictures
this is a surprising deal because he
sort of
has publicly slammed you know these
streaming services in a few years he
said that
a few years ago he said that netflix
like movies shouldn't be contenders at
the oscars
oh i guess they still shouldn't then i
think that's for the best take your own
advice stephen
um also financial terms of the deal were
not disclosed well so
let's use like a point of reference how
many movies is it
like a couple it's a multi-year deal
because like adam sandler i think was
contracted
netflix to do like five movies and he
got paid like 300 million and i think
steven spielberg would get paid more
than adam sandler yeah no i'm sure
the money was right yeah so i it says to
know that even steven steven spielberg
can be bought yeah you know because i
never thought i had much in common with
steven spielberg but here we are
here we are the thing is is that um i
feel like you know a lot of people will
be excited about this like
personally i like to watch like bad
movies like i don't think i've ever even
seen a steven spielberg movie like i've
never seen jaws
what else e.t that one was good oh
sorry i take it back hold on let me go
to stephen schiller's list is
an incredible film so amazing hold on
let me oh also
i saw a story today that i meant to send
to you are we talking about adrian brody
no but what do you want oh no why what
do you want to say
adrian brody was spotted out or he's
dating i can't remember who it was but
it was really shocking give me oh my god
so he's not dating georgina chapman
oh that's who it was oh he's been dating
her has he yeah we've spoken about this
no we have it because they were spotted
they were at tribeca film festival they
walked the carpet together and i was
shook they have been dating like since
the old since
our last studio no yeah i didn't know i
think that's
honestly an amazing couple like you know
what justice for georgina chapman like
she has been through a lot
and adrian brody is a stand-up guy i
think i did sit next to him at a dinner
party once that's like my favorite story
yeah no they've been dating for a while
i'm glad to see it's going well
are you ready for the movies that have
been directed by steven's yes
ready player one never saw it but i see
it everywhere
the post oh no i didn't see that one oh
no i didn't see that one either birds of
spies
missed that one too bfg
you must have missed it lincoln saw it
fell asleep three separate times
by the way by the way the nerve we are
still waiting on an apology
from steven spielberg for subjecting us
to that trash movie it was so bad we all
fell asleep
yeah me you and margo honked the [ __ ]
out for the whole movie
tintin never heard of it war horse
must have missed it war of the worlds
yeah the terminal
um indiana jones heard of it
munich never saw it but should see it
good story i think
well a bad story well yeah like a story
that you should know thank you
catch me if you can oh so good
leo's best work minority report never
heard of it
artificial intelligence sounds good
saving private ryan heard of it never
seen it yeah i've heard it's good
amistad never seen it basically what i'm
trying to say
is like you know this is great i don't
know if i'll be personally impacted
because i don't really flock towards
steven spielberg's movie like i'm i'm
not that person it's like gotta go see
the new spielberg film you know
yeah i don't know maybe that's something
that comes with age
100 because you know i'm really um
who's the guy who did midnight in paris
woody allen oh sorry ew nevermind right
no
yeah no you're 100 right no that's not
him oh i'm thinking of martin scorsese
okay he did the irishman
yes and he did um our favorite movie
shutter island
did he right i don't know by the way
shutter island is the movie that
started it all here at the morning time
yes we have shutter island to thank for
everything yes martin scorsese so i feel
like i'm more of a scorsese kind of girl
than a spielberg kind of gal
but i don't know maybe i'll just start
maturing and flock towards spielberg but
i'm happy for all the people who like
you know the cinephiles who are excited
about this spielberg
netflix deal i'm just personally um
probably not going to see anything any
of that here are some scorsese
definitely has some that you
that you've never seen unless steven
spielberg is directing the new season of
love is blind i probably am not going to
see it unless steven spielberg will be
responsible for reviving this society
which
by the way i think is spielberg level
jackie i completely agree and that
should be part of his deal i wish steven
spielberg had like a granddaughter
who listened to the toast like pops
please please please it's such a good
idea and honestly like he could make it
brilliant
but he would never do tv a hundred
percent well it's not tv it's like
series i could see him doing a series
like
yeah like a mini series like a queen's
gambit mm-hmm yeah
um okay you want to talk about martin
scorsese you want to move on
sure because other movies that are
martin scorsese or as lala ken calls him
marty the wolf of wall street seen it
aviator no you never saw that one it was
good
the departed i never saw it but i've
heard i've heard good things
casino i think i've seen that yes of
course i've seen that one robert de niro
but there's also a lot a lot of others
that we haven't seen so
yeah i just think i'm more of a scorsese
kind of girl
okay cool cool and bella that's italian
thank you for the pronunciation you're
welcome are you ready for our next story
sure oh no i'm not you're not because
i'm feeling very tired
weak
uh oh i think she needs some liquid iv
to revive her
how did you know today's episode is
brought to you by liquid iv
the hydration multiplier plus and moon
support is a cutting-edge blend of
vitamin c
zinc and wellmune in convenient
single-serve packets to help strengthen
your immune system
vitamin c is well known to help protect
your body and support good health
zinc the second most abundant trace
mineral in your body supports immune
cell health and
function the blend is powered by ctt
cellular transport technology which is
designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water and other
nutrients the optimal ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium delivers water and
key nutrients into the bloodstream
faster
so if you have trouble drinking water um
which i do it's just like not something
i'm particularly good at
liquid iv can just really help you out
because
you get two to three times more hydrated
from a bottle of water that has liquid
iv
so it makes it easier for you to drink
water it tastes really really good and
it just helps you out throughout the day
like not feel fatigued
not if i don't drink a lot of water i
get like migraines so there's just a lot
of really good benefits to liquid iv
also a little trick of the trade if
you're hungover a liquid iv can truly
save a life get your liquid iv hydration
multiplier plus
immune support in bulk at costco or you
can order online and get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the promo code toast at checkout
when you purchase liquid iv you're
joining the mission to help people live
better everywhere
because with every purchase they are
donating a serving of liquid iv to
someone in need
so again that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today
using promo code toast at liquidive.com
love it thank you for that claudia you
are so welcome i'm feeling so much
better
i now feel as though we are ready me too
t-pain
says that usher's comments about
autotune made him depressed for four
years
oh my god i feel like if i've learned
anything in the last couple of years
t-pain is a pee job have you changed his
name to tea job
have you seen this story no t-pain says
he fell into a four-year-long depression
after usher told him that his use of
autotune wrecked the music industry
the rapper makes the stunning revelation
on the upcoming net
netflix series this is pop saying the
statement from his famous friend
caused him deep pain he said usher was
my friend i really respect usher and he
said i'm gonna tell you something man
you kind of [ __ ] up music and then he
was like yeah man you really [ __ ] up
music for real singers
i was like what did i do i came out and
i used auto tune
i'm literally gonna cry no this is so
upsetting
he was like yeah you [ __ ] it up i'm
like but i used it i didn't tell
everybody else to start using it is this
what you said you wanted to get justice
for when you said earlier the show
because
justice for t paid yes this is so mean
and disgraceful and like okay usher
like not cool not cool oh
and also when i think of auto-tune i
mean of course t-pain's music uses
auto-tune but
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that he ruined
the music industry first of all i
wouldn't say that second i wouldn't
really say t-pain uses auto-tune he kind
of uses like a
megaphone it's like it's just an effect
auto-tune takes a bad voice it makes it
a good voice
whereas i think his t-pain put like a
different spin it like it's like
it's like also like i think the issue
with auto-tune is when people use it
and they're trying to hide the fact that
they're using it and they're setting
this like unrealistic
standard of what things sound like yeah
but that was never what t-pain was doing
like it's
the the sound was auto-tuned and i just
want to say like
that's the t-pain music of like the
early 2000's
[ __ ] slaps and a lot of people um
like copied that method like in a lot of
popular songs like you hear people
masking their voice with like a robot
type and i think it's cool
usher would say that that ruined music
no it created a new genre
yeah like not everyone was blessed with
you know the vocal glands of an angel
usher some of us have to work hard for
it
i think this is so rude and like like
elitist like okay good for you and your
perfect voice like some of us are trying
to make it out here and we don't have
like the god-given
have to get creative yeah yeah i'm not
bad about this at all um but you know
people did say i used too much
auto-tune on my toes and how did that
make you feel
um where's the lie you know yeah it's
like facetune
it's like facetune and honestly like
what you want the song to sound worse
just because i'm too proud
to use autotune no and i do have a good
voice like i have nothing to hide
i totally agree kind of time we gonna
have a good time
yeah that was good tell him a thousand
hands up to this guy
stream toast available on spotify on all
music streaming platforms netflix's show
this is papa's an eight part series
exploring untold stories from some of
the most notable
notable moments in pop music history
well that sounds good yeah the series
also features interviews with abbas
benny anderson shania twain brandy
carlisle chuck d
baby face orville peck members of boys
to men and the backstreet boys
the series will be released in full on
june 22nd what would you like that's any
day now it's today
oh how exciting that actually does sound
really good sounds like a vh1 type of
show like the fabulous life of you know
yeah yeah um i'm very excited about this
i think that
i'm constantly looking for new content
and i'll probably be watching this
speaking of the backstreet boys i
watched like a podcast interview that aj
mclean did and it was really inspiring
you know he's sober since 2001 or
something yeah we do
you knew that too yes i knew that too
but you know how and why he got sober
like they were out um somewhere throwing
out the pitch at an
mlb game and he like partied the whole
night before he said he was going
through an ounce of cocaine at night
and like a half a bottle of jack daniels
a night and he woke up to do the mlb
thing he was like i just don't want to
go and
kevin from the backstreet boys who's not
kevin fetterline right nope
okay he barged in and like broke down
the door and like literally screamed and
like said
like really like hard truths to aj
mclean and he was like you're dead to me
and aj mclean flew to phoenix and got
into rehab and it's been sober ever
since
wow and i think that's why the
backstreet boys are still together like
they're truly a band of brothers and
they're there for each other
literally even in you know when it's not
easy wow and even little me like knew
that kevin was you know
such a great guy well little me thought
kevin from backstreet boys legitimately
was kevin fetterline up until a year ago
yeah also little you was like on the
fence about the whole debate
as you always are don't spoil anything i
detail it all in my new york times
best-selling book claudia ashright girl
with no job
no that's not the name of the book girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram thirst monster available
literally anywhere
it's new york times bestseller don't
come for me um thank you for that and
also interesting story about aj mclean
what podcast was it i don't know it just
came up on tick tock so like
it was just really it might not actually
i think it was et canada not a podcast
but he was like sitting in front of a
podcast mic
it was just really inspiring no it was
like a podcast mike yeah
yeah you know a podcast mike you're a
podcaster yeah like this one yeah
big and dramatic by the way i have been
meaning to say this on the show for
weeks when you were somewhere and i had
like friends and family week
ben sat next to me and after the show
he's like i don't know how you sit in
front of these mics because they say
right here
heil and i'm like what and he's right
can you see it on the side yeah
no i have one right here h-e-i-l i guess
the name of this company is heil which
is just like not a great name for two
jewish podcasters
but it is what it is and i literally
never noticed it until ben pointed it
out
that's really funny it was so funny wow
okay are ready for our next story a
little more content news today's just
like a day of content but this is an
interesting one
sure the downfall of hillsong church
will be explored in a new discovery plus
docu-series oh that sounds
fabulous called breaking hill song
oh that's salacious i mean even before
the documentary i have so many questions
about what go
went on in hillsong like justin selena
haley so many celebrities so many
celebrities so many celebrities
like what happened but also i actually
know a few people who belong to the
church and they
love it like they're not like cult like
they just they go to church and that's
the church they go to
and they love it they say it's like a
really amazing so i'm just curious like
where it all went wrong
yeah but i also i mean i haven't really
followed and i'm sure breaking hillsong
will explain but it always kind of
seemed like this church is a mega church
there's so many
members but there was also this
celebrity arm that did like the
marketing and
the pr and i think that arm like started
to fall apart and i think it took the
whole thing down
really you don't think that the
congregation is intact
oh i don't know it's breaking hillsong
makes it seem like it's over it okay
well
hillsong's charged high profile
challenges will supe soon play out on
the small screen
discovery plus on monday announced a
three-part documentary expose
called breaking hillsong which will
stream on the service as a limited
series
the project will chronicle the headline
making world of global star-studded mega
church hillsong and the downfall of its
ultra-hip celebrity senior pastor
carl lentz who was once a guest on this
show this series will feature exclusive
interviews with people like
ranin kareem who claims she had a five
month affair with lentz and profiles of
current and former members of the church
who have come forward and masked to
share harrowing stories of the trauma
abuse financial and labor exploitation
homophobia and racism that created a
culture of chaos at hillsong
according to the release oh man i mean
this is actually like a a good subject
for a documentary i feel like recently
we've been getting like
the documentaries nobody asked for like
you know there's no real drama
like when we were just watching that we
work one it was like they were just
trying so hard to like make drama
yeah wasn't that crazy no really but i
actually feel like this will uncover
a lot and i think this is great for the
streaming wars discovery plus
i haven't been i mean i've been telling
you guys discovery plus has
got their [ __ ] together i mean for
someone who's so passionate about it you
didn't give me your password when i
asked repeatedly
so i never got to experience it it
doesn't sound like me no it actually
is you maybe it was another girl it's
you but you're not like other girls it
was you but i
i don't even know where i would start to
know what my password is
i don't even know what email address
actually it's my email address you
didn't even like try
and like give me that that seems like so
much effort you know what if you want a
discovery plus like support
why should we be paying for multiple
supports
i just did subscribe to paramount plus
i'm kind of over it now
that's what happens i read a study it
was like so scientific
you are constantly reading studies that
the average so with the streaming more
is it's like how many services will
people
subscribe for it average what people are
doing is seven
wow but i feel like and i don't think
i'm the only one who does this like i
pay for paramount plus
and then i use like a family netflix
like i obliviously so you use the system
but i would say
even i'm sure that's like most people do
that with their family i'm sure but
still like how many of the platforms are
even
interested in going to find a way to get
so i think seven
including like you're the way that you
steal other people's passwords
you probably use seven of them yeah the
only one i really haven't downloaded or
tried was discovery plus
okay but there's like no this might be
the thing to get me there yeah
you are really missing out discovery
plus has like the most soothing content
well aside from this but
these days when you open your apple tv
and you like just you don't know what
you're going to watch you're going to
look for something where do you go
i really try to avoid that like i always
turn my tv on with purpose
i'm like oh my god you are so annoying
just that's the question no no like i
literally don't even do that anymore
like i always know what i'm gonna watch
next because my content plate is so full
okay so all right let me ask a different
question for all the streaming services
that have come out in the last couple
years what is your favorite one
i mean like as of now it can change but
mine's hbo max oh i don't really
i like it the big shot was on there
friends is on there i loved
hacks all sex in the city that i
rewatched recently was on there
netflix is actually like literally my
least favorite platform i don't know if
i can give you an answer because i just
like know what i'm going to watch i
search it and i hope that where
it is i already subscribe i'm so sorry
for the disappointing answer i mean
like literally the biggest
disappointment of all time so sorry i'll
think about it harder i'll have an
answer for you next time well when does
this documentary come out because i'm
definitely going to be keeping up with
the lenses
um the documentary comes out it doesn't
say
cool cool so maybe like just got started
we'll keep you posted we'll keep you
abreast
are you ready for our fifth and final
story is it the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by
the zebra yes think about all the
purchases you made in quarantine those
late night pizza deliveries the mini
succulents
there's one of your biggest purchases of
the year insurance americans overspend
on car and home insurance by the
billions every year
and that's money that could have been
spent on more retail therapy and that's
where the zebra comes in
the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site for car and
home insurance
in minutes you can compare policies from
every major provider for free
all in one independent marketplace after
a few questions the zebra pairs people
with the right insurance company for
them helping everyone save time and
money
buy online or over the phone with one of
their license insurance agents
there are no hidden fees or a fine print
about your personal information best of
all the zebra has no stake in the policy
you choose they're just there to help
you find the right coverage
make insurance your smartest purchase
yet visit the zebra.com
toast to get your free quote today
that's visit that's
the zebra dot com slash toast again the
zebra dot com slash t-o-a-s-t
thank you for letting us know that the
zebra is sponsoring
the final story
i've been getting a lot of complaints
about that what i've gotten so much love
where do we go from here i think we have
to
people say 50 don't like it and 50
love it we just have to decide how we
feel about it
okay that's real i'm so glad you brought
that up
because like some days i'm really into
it and some days i'm not oh i think are
you into it every day
yes like because once we get into it
like it gives the the waste of
serotonin that we made i'm sorry you
didn't make it a story
chloe and tristan because i didn't want
to offend you well no because you didn't
want me you don't want me to say i was
right i didn't want you to fall asleep
on the couch saying how exhausted you
are i
am we need to talk about it okay please
talk about the story
okay i mean here's the officially called
officially quality quiz period more
cheating allegations
tana mojo is involved one tristan
three girls in a room let me first one
at the party yeah tana mojo
tweeted something about her birthday
party over the weekend
i didn't choose because i was scared of
your reaction no because now i feel even
more justified justified in me wanting
to cancel them
okay okay all i know to tweet about my
birthday party last night is that
tristan thompson was one of the first
attendees
like babe wears true and someone
responded to it
in like a mean way and chloe liked it
some person responded
shut the [ __ ] up this screams attention
seeking at its finest because you know
damn well that that man is gonna make
headlines over anything pertaining to
women
you're a bird don't speak untrue either
weird [ __ ]
and chloe liked that tweet then
literally because i just want to say
like him being
on time for a party like doesn't say
anything about anything
no no no but then the daily mail like
had this story and pictures of clo of
him at i think this same party
entering a room with three girls coming
out looking all to shout out
maybe they were you know cleaning but i
have other ideas
they were doing tick tock dances yeah
and that does make one look quite
disheveled yeah it's exhausting
but then it seems chloe broke up with
him so maybe she knows something for
sure
that we yeah so they released a
statement and honestly like i feel
justified
in my feelings from before like of
course we have to report on it and it's
exhausting to keep up with these two
um especially after we just like saw
this keeping up with kardashians reunion
um these two are a circus
you're so mean to them am i look what
they constantly put us through
no you know not even them because i
can't even blame chloe but like girl
like how many times we're gonna take
someone back before they learn
i don't know i feel like we were like
from the way that we saw it we all
understood why she took him back no and
i feel like this last season of
kardashians was really like a pr
machine for tristan because we were all
like oh my god he's so cute he's trying
so hard
all leave the past in the past but that
is just so crazy that he would go and do
that again i
i'm sure chloe is beside herself and
done with him
period so is this the third time or
fourth if you count the girl from the no
jumper podcast
fourth if you count her i don't know if
i'm she posted like a cryptic message
you know of course she did
yeah i don't know if i believe that but
it's three maybe four yeah
but that we know of yeah and so it's
definitely more than that
got it i can't believe you didn't choose
that like while you're looking up for me
like no when i heard the news yesterday
i think zach told me i was like okay
cool
like we're not talking about it no okay
cool it's just like irrelevant at this
point like it's one of those things you
hear about so much about someone like
you just don't care anymore you lose
interest
yeah you really do we're fatigued but i
just wanted to the real reason i brought
this out today
justice for you justice for me like i
and justice for everyone
who's tired of being tired and i tried
to give you justice like
in the form of not talking about
exhaustion but like we are
the millennial like pop culture morning
show that's literally the only thing
that happened yesterday
for sure so the headline they broke up
it's done
i think it's actually done this time i
hope so yeah i've moved on
yeah and i think maybe like chloe needs
to start um
dating different types of people like
maybe someone who's not famous
no i don't agree like that episode where
mj and
chris like that guy from dick's sporting
goods yeah they go like looking for
cute guys for chloe and they found so
many who would have been like she really
should try going out with someone
not famous regular job like that guy
from dick's sporting good
was loki hot and he was a trainer and
chloe's always looking for new trainers
yeah and like mj said she needs an
accountant
yeah mj knows what's up she needs a
businessman bow
yeah for sure okay now it's time for the
final story
it's the fun take it away
[Music]
are you gonna yell me you can't rush out
you can't rush art
okay now i don't feel safe go go go no
no it's fine forget it it's the [ __ ]
thing i don't know
okay okay no do it do it no nobody wants
to hear me saying yes they do oh don't
say that
suddenly she's shot okay i'm not good
enough
come on stop with the beats okay
[Music]
stunning thank you okay well the fifth
and final story is a little science news
because scientists say that they found
a solution for the hiccups enough with
these scientists
why don't you give us real solutions you
know i don't know
how to be you know how to lose weight
with doing without doing anything like
that is some valuable science honestly
i consider this valuable science and
maybe if you suffered from the hiccups
you would
know what it's like to value this piece
of science but i don't no i've gotten
hiccups like it's definitely annoying
it's not like a
you know life urgent like no
it's like the most annoying thing to
have hiccups
but like which scientists like what else
should these scientists be working on
i feel like there's more pressing issues
number of things that they should be
working on but instead
they've they've invented a straw that
apparently cures the hiccups okay wait
let me get this straight
straw it's a shaw is it metal
oh unclear because it looks like it
might be of the adrian brody
no adrian grenier yeah did not put his
neck on the line just for scientists to
invent a new no it's definitely not it's
not
not disposable like it's something that
you would use multiple times multiple
times okay
so here's the thinking when you get
hiccups the diaphragm and the
intercostal muscles suddenly contract
the subsequent abrupt intake of air
causes the opening between the vocal
folds
known as the glottis to shut resulting
in a hick sound
often to the embarrassment of the
afflicted and the amusement of others
who wrote this
the guardian but while home remedies
abound a team of scientists say they
have come up with a new answer
called the forced inspiratory section
and swallow tool the fi
sst and patented as hick-away
it's 14 it's a plastic device and it's a
rigid l-shaped straw
that has a mouthpiece at one end and an
adjustable cap with the pressure valve
in the form of a small hole at the other
hiccuping people place the device into a
glass of water and use it to sip
that's it yeah i'm getting one
no i mean like it's good anyone's not an
ad
i just feel like the scientists
should kind of be like refocusing on
more you know important issues like
there's
so much wrong in the world you know
medical scientific
climate like there's all these things
and like these guys are like
we made a strong you know no i think
these are small wins like you were just
at dinner with the snatcher the other
night and she had the hiccups yeah and
like honestly it was so funny i never
left so hard in my life so like why
would the scientists want to take that
away from us
no i didn't we were scientists racking
up scientists are protecting those
like there's okay for the first few
they're funny but then they are so
annoying they are they're so nice and
they hurt
you know i'm just being negative like
great this is awesome but like it took
us until 2021 to solve the hiccups
i mean some people think they have the
solution and this isn't you know 100
but i will be trying it yeah honestly
all these like you know drink water
upside down someone has to scare you
hold your breath for 8 seconds none of
that [ __ ] works like they just go away
no you just have to like go to sleep
yeah no like you just have to
like like stop no yeah no because then
like they go away and you're like oh my
god it worked you scared me no it's just
like the time was up for the hiccups
you know yeah so those are the fast life
stories feel as though you definitely
needed to know them you definitely
definitely did and i learned a lot like
adrian brody and
georgina chapman are dating like i can't
get over them and they've been dating
for years that's crazy to me
um so yeah anything else you want to say
before we wrap up our show
no i mean enjoy our interview with lala
it was such a fun one to record
and for sure we will see you tomorrow
for hump day and i
i think du will be here yeah he will i
really do and we've got deer toasters
tomorrow so tomorrow's gonna be very
exciting day thank you so much for
spending your morning with us and i
think one of the real housewives is on
tonight
right oh yeah i want to say new orleans
beverly hills whatever whatever it is
we'll be watching it um
thank you so much for listening to the
oh it's new york okay thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the five stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have ready to cast box all the places so
whenever we listen to podcasts find out
this morning chelsea five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
hope you guys have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day